uh now we're going to turn to something
i'd actually rather not have to report
why well i love this country i want this
country to be
uh number one in all things i want every
american to be successful free
prosperous safe secure no matter who the
president is sadly now our country is in
economic turmoil and it is getting far
worse with each passing day all because
joe biden and his radicalized new green
deal socialist policies are destroying
the good economy he inherited during his
inauguration joel laughably promised to
be a unifier a pragmatic moderate he's
anything but instead the months that
have followed he has bowed at the altar
of new green deal socialism and that is
where he is today he decided to pursue
the radical agenda of climate-obsessed
elitists over poor and middle-class
families that are now suffering greatly
because of his policies he has decided
to restrict domestic oil and gas
production that causes gas prices energy
crisis the price to heat and cool your
home everything you buy is now
skyrocketing you decided to push through
trillions of dollars in new spending
that increases inflation guess what that
means your dollar doesn't go as far in
fact according to the latest numbers the
inflation is now at a three decade high
gas is up by 50 percent meat and poultry
is up by 12 percent if you want a steak
it's 25 percent higher furniture 12
transportation costs up nearly 20
percent everything that you buy from
every store you go to every service
that's provided to you is now more
expensive joe biden doesn't care doesn't
care that everyone is everything is now
more expensive doesn't care that your
your quality of life is diminishing
daily doesn't care that the money in
your bank account is now worth a lot
less the fragile opinions of his wealthy
well-connected green new deal socialist
visionaries are much more important take
a look
guess what that's in the recovery act
i'm assuming that that's in the pullback
better bill
which is not going to raise taxes one
single cent it's totally paid for you
hear a lot about the supply chains in
the news but frankly
not a lot of people are clear have a
clear understanding whether they have a
phd or they didn't go to school
about how a supply chain works more
products are being delivered than ever
before
that's because people have a little more
breathing room than they did last year
and that's a good thing
but it also means we got higher demand
for goods at the same time we're facing
disruptions and the supplies to make
those goods
there's a res this is a recipe for
delays and for higher prices and people
are feeling it
they're feeling it do everything keep
paying this much for a gallon of gas now
to answer joe's question yes we have
been sounding the alarm about rising gas
prices since joe biden's first week in
office that's when he restricted
domestic production of oil and gas and
that's when we gave up a great gift it's
called energy independence then he went
on to nominate this woman to the
treasury department take a look
troubled industries and firms that are
in transitioning and here what i'm
thinking about is primarily coal
industry and oil and gas industry a lot
of the smaller players in that industry
are
uh going to probably
go bankrupt in in in short order at
least we want them to go bankrupt if we
want to tackle climate change right
she wants to bankrupt the energy
industry in the name of what climate
change so bowing at the altar of climate
change thank god she's yet to be
confirmed hope hopefully she will not be
joe manchin i don't think this helps
west virginia but remember it's not just
this nominee even biden himself stated
that he was perfectly comfortable
sacrificing high-paying jobs in the
energy sector in order to enact his
radical green new deal agenda even
talked about putting ceos of energy
companies in jail take a look
would you be willing to sacrifice some
of that growth
even knowing potentially that it could
displace thousands maybe hundreds of
thousands of blue-collar workers in the
interest of transitioning to that
greener economy the answer is yes
the answer is yes if we don't stop using
fuels
we're all dead doing away with any
subsidies for fossil fuels number one
number two holding them liable
for what they have done particularly in
those cases where your underserved
neighborhoods and you you know the deal
okay and by the way when they don't or
when they're deliberate put them in jail
that's what i'm from i'm not joking
put put them in jail and by the way if
you lost your high paying career job in
the energy sector joe biden's message to
you is pretty much drop dead lo and
behold biden did sacrifice high-paying
jobs gas prices are spiking it's hurting
the poor in the middle class the most
he's prioritized his radical
environmental views over the poor and
middle class in this country that are
being crushed by the high energy prices
that he created and is responsible for
on top of the inflation that he's
creating biden is now begging opec and
russia to pump more oil they keep
rejecting him keep raising prices
instead of going back to the successful
energy policies of donald trump remember
we had gas under two bucks a gallon with
donald trump all joe would need to do is
merely ask texas alaska oklahoma north
dakota and guess what he wouldn't have
to beg and americans would get their
jobs back the ones he said dropped dead
to
anyway as we continue meanwhile joe's
energy secretary thinks that's all very
funny as you saw jennifer granholm
what is the grand home plan to increase
oil production in america
oh my god
that is hilarious wood that i had the
magic wand on this as you know of course
oil is a global market it is controlled
by a cartel that cartel is called opec
and they made a decision yesterday that
they were not going to increase beyond
what they were already planning
oil and gas is a global market that's
true under trump it wasn't controlled by
the quote cartel opec america was energy
independent we didn't take a single
barrel from saudi arabia when donald
trump left the presidency we were a net
exporter of both oil and gas now america
is in a position of weakness and begging
opec almost daily to produce more oil